Pope Francis originally called the
meeting known as a synod to chart what
he called a more merciful approach to
families a draft text of the closing
statement was circulated earlier in the
week saying the church should recognize
the gifts and qualities homosexuals have
to offer the Christian community that
wording was removed in the final text
trailer gears elite ability the church
says that people who have homosexual
tendencies should not be discriminated
against but that marriage is possible
just between one man and one woman
things are very simple we can repeat it
a million times but they do not change
that the Soviet was your movie bit
Illuminati volta my quistis saw Michael
the two weeks of talks let the bishops
deeply divided some observers say it's a
breakthrough for the church even to be
talking about such controversial issues
yeah give us a technicality the results
show where the church stands right now
it is not concerned with finding a quick
compromise the church is confronting the
conflict openly and the answer has not
yet been found does it's the amount of
hargitay nuneaton chitinous many
ordinary Catholics say they would like
to see the church progress on matters
like remarried divorcees there needs to
be more tolerance for things that have
been around for centuries and centuries
which is people not being able to say
together when they're married they
should work at it and work very hard in
another move that may spark controversy
the church prepared to beatify Pope
pulled the sits later on Sunday
beatification is one step shy of
sainthood Paul the six was Pope in the
1960s and 70s he issued the Catholic
Church's total ban on contraception
including the pill and condoms which
still stands today